bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check up votre magazine santé
bien-être ce mois ci nous parlerons
cancer et notamment d'un dispositif mis
en place pour mieux connaître l'impact
social de cette maladie au programme
également dans ce nouveau numéro des 20
ans de l'association sidaction nous en
avons profité pour interroger des jeunes
sur le sida mais tout d'abord le dossier
de ce nouveau numéro le don de moelle
osseuse dans 80% des cas les malades qui
ont besoin d'une greffe sont atteint
d'une leucémie et le traitement par
chimiothérapie n'est plus suffisant pour
faire un don il suffit d'être âgé entre
18 et 50 ans et d'être en bonne santé un
geste qui peut sauver des vies et l'
agence de biomédecine avec d'autres
partenaires tentent de faire entendre ce
message un dossier réalisé avec elodie
moines et patrick et jacques de dixmude
rebecca ruimy va bientôt fêter ses dix
ans de greffe en pleine semaine de
mobilisation pour le don de moelle
osseuse cdn yvelinoise est un bel
exemple d'espoir face à la maladie
touché par un premier cancer à l'âge de
21 ans elle est ensuite atteinte d'une
leucémie aiguë à l'âge de 25 ans s'il en
est aujourd'hui guéri c'est grâce au don
de moelle osseuse d'un donneur allemand
moi je l'appelle mon frère de sang
puisque je suis sa copie minutes à faire
que j'ai changé le groupe sanguin je
fumais à plessé je suis devenu au plus
tout comme mon bonheur dans la
population générale la probabilité pour
un malade de trouver un donneur
compatible c'est une chance sur un
million un chiffre extrêmement faible
pour maximiser les chances l'objectif
cette année est de recruter 2400
nouveaux donneurs pour la région ile de
france à noter qu'en 2013 plus de 25000
d'honneur de la région étaient inscrits
sur le registre national
la moelle osseuse en tissu au rôle
primordial dans notre corps puisque
c'est elle qui produit les cellules du
sang la moins de 16 et d'un réseau du
squelette et c'est elle qui produit les
cellules du sang c'est-à-dire les
globules rouges qui transportent
l'oxygène les globules blancs qui
luttent contre les infections et les
plaquettes qui interviennent pour
arrêter les hémorragies ça n'a rien à
voir avec la moelle épinière qui est le
transfert du fut nerveux qui se trouve
dans la colonne vertébrale
première étape pour devenir donneur
s'inscrire sur un registre c'est ce qu'a
fait laurent ce en se rendant à
l'établissement français du sang
enchaîné une de ses collègues de travail
avait un fils atteint de leucémie est en
attente d'une greffe de moelle osseuse
c'est là qu'elle a pris conscience de la
nécessité des dons deux ans après son
inscription et la prise de sang
obligatoire on l'appelle pour lui dire
car malade a besoin d'elle elle a alors
52 ans moi je me suis dit que c'était le
moment ou jamais de deyne vraiment
vraiment vraiment utile à quelque chose
et à quelqu'un c'est assez important et
après ma licence ancien assez vite donc
on est on est très bien pris en charge
on a une seule personne qui s'occupe de
vous bon alors là du coup on a le droit
à un check up complet l'avantagé que du
coup on sait qu'on est en très bonne
santé laurence prend alors le temps de
s'organiser puis vient le jour j alors
qu'elle est sous anesthésie générale le
médecin lui ponctionne la moelle osseuse
au niveau du bassin un geste sans risque
puisque le tissu se reconstitue
naturellement pour rappel il existe deux
façons de faire un don la première comme
laurence et le prélèvement dans les eaux
du bassin et nécessitent 48 heures à
l'hôpital la deuxième se fait par
prélèvement dans le sang et il faut
alors compter deux matinées de quatre
heures dans les deux cas aucune
complication pour le donneur si ce n'est
de légères douleurs au niveau du dos il
ya quand même beaucoup de gens ont peur
de tout ce qui inspire alisation 1 du
milieu médical si pourtant on est en
france et je crois qu'on a la meilleure
médecine au monde ou presque donc
on prend quand même pas beaucoup de
risques des dons avec très peu de risque
qui permettent de guérir des malades
aujourd'hui rebecca des examens de sang
tous les six mois pour vérifier qu'elle
est en bonne santé juriste comédienne
professionnelle saxophoniste ou encore
aux membres de l'association laurette
fugain elle ne s'arrête jamais et
profite pleinement de ce qu'elle appelle
sa deuxième vie le 30 septembre prochain
je vais fêter mes dix ans de greffe donc
c'est juste une chance extraordinaire et
et ça m'a permis de voilà de réaliser
tout tout tout plein de projets et
pouvoir revivre me dire que j'avais une
deuxième vie vous êtes véritablement
comme un enfant qui vient de naître ça
veut dire que vous n'avez plus de
mémoire immunitaire tout a disparu et
c'est pour ça qu'on est extrêmement
fragile c'est pour ça que à l'issue de
la grève on sort dans la rue avec un
masque pour se protéger de l'extérieur
puisque la moindre petite bactérie peut
être dangereuse pour un malade qui vient
de recevoir une greffe elle raconte son
combat dans un livre qu'elle aimerait
voir publier pour ses dix ans de greffe
un livre qui parle avant tout de son
message d'espoir
la médecine n'est pas une science exacte
et les médecins ont des pronostics bien
évidemment ils sont là pour vous dire ce
qu'il en est je savais que je devais
mourir mais je me suis battu j'ai cru en
la vie et est pour moi je me suis
toujours dit que je serai plus forte que
mes deux camps faire que j'ai lu voilà
donc j'ai eu la chance d'avoir ben je
suis pas plaint de plein de vie puisque
aussi je suis le fruit de plein de
donneurs qui vont du nez du sang des
plaquettes pour continuer mes
traitements mais surtout je suis là
grâce à un donneur de moelle osseuse
pour la 9ème semaine de mobilisation
pour le don de moelle osseuse l' agence
de biomédecine s'est donné comme
objectif de recruter 18 mille nouveaux
donneurs d'ici 2015 l'objectif est de
taille diversifier les profils
génétiques
comme rebecca il ya quelques années plus
de 2000 personnes atteintes d'une
maladie grave du sang ont aujourd'hui
besoin d'une greffe en france
nous sommes ici et l'établissement
français du sang au général derrière moi
les acteurs y voient de la ligue
nationale contre le cancer ce sont eux
qui ont mis en place il ya bientôt de
quatre ans un dispositif pour mieux
comprendre l'impact social du cancer
cette année l'accent a été mis sur le
retour à l'emploi des malades jonathan
vilma pour les images
lorsqu'on parle de cancer on évoque
avant tout son aspect médical pourtant
la maladie un impact tout aussi
important sur la vie sociale et
économique des personnes touchées pour
lutter contre ces difficultés la ligue
nationale contre le cancer a mis en
place il ya quatre ans le dos parce
c'est le dispositif d'observation pour
l'action sociale le comité des yvelines
a présenté les résultats pour l'année
2013 est l'un des constats importants
c'est la difficulté du retour à l'emploi
pour les malades dans une période où il
ya un taux de chômage extrêmement
important des employeurs qui de temps en
temps se dire mais qu'est ce que je vais
faire de cette personne qui était malade
et qui n'aura pas le rendement ou plus
le rendement que je souhaitais ou qui
suite à des arts et littérature n'est
plus tout à fait au courant de ce qu'on
fait maintenant voilà par exemple des
difficultés réelles il y a deux ans
alors qu'elle travaillait au service
communication d'une grande banque
française mathilde apprend qu'elle a un
cancer du sein au delà de l'isolément ce
qu'elle a mal vécu c'est la difficulté à
évaluer le moment où elle allait pouvoir
revenir travailler rapidement on m'a dit
mais alors quand est-ce que tu reviens
quand est-ce que tu reviens et ils
comprennent pas
l'entreprise a du mal à admettre que
vous ne soyez pas capable de dire que
vous ne soyez pas dans le même état de
fatigue d'une semaine à l'autre qu'un
jour ça va et que trois jours après ça
va plus
et ça c'est extrêmement compliqué à
gérer déjà soi même mais en plus à faire
admettre à un service dans une entrée
dans une entreprise ont d'abord revenu
en temps partiel thérapeutique et l'a
finalement décidé de quitter son
entreprise actuellement en rémission
elle est devenue auto entrepreneuse dans
l'événementiel pour pallier à ces
difficultés de retour au travail le
dispositif avance notamment une solution
mais anticiper la reprise de l'activité
et en parler avec son médecin du travail
beaucoup de gens ont peur d'aller voir
leur médecin de travail parce qu'ils se
disent il va devoir parler il va tout
raconter à ma direction des ressources
humaines à mon employeur accès non
médecin du travail est tenu au secret
professionnel comme tous les médecins et
donc ça ça n'existe pas et vraiment ce
sont des acteurs extrêmement important
pour permettre justement dans les
meilleures conditions possibles le
retour à l'emploi d'après les enquêtes
dans les yvelines 48 % des malades
atteints d'un cancer déclaré avoir une
situation économique est difficile
le sidaction célèbre ses 20 ans 20 ans
de lutte contre le sida qui aujourd'hui
inquiète malheureusement moi et pourtant
chaque année on dénombre encore près de
3 millions de nouvelles contaminations
dans le monde lors de cette édition la
campagne du sidaction était orienté vers
les jeunes un reportage réalisé avec
elodie moines et patrick jacq de luxe
mettant
le sidaction fête ses 20 ans l'année
dernière 40 mille personnes ont pu être
mises sous traitement grâce aux dons
récoltés par l'association de lutte
contre le vih ce début avril plusieurs
actions de mobilisation se déroule sur
le territoire au lycée descartes de
montigny le bretonneux les élèves élus
au conseil de la vie lycéenne et des
infirmières et des cpe tiennent un stand
d'information et vendent des objets
sidaction l'occasion de sensibiliser les
lycéens cette maladie c'est quelque
chose qui la sexualité car un quorum
tout petit peu tabou vivre un corps
lycée et donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
pousser parce que c'est vraiment à ce
moment là qui est premier rapport sexuel
les pousse à se protéger est elle censée
viser surtout sidaction est aussi un peu
tout ce qui était resté en rapport avec
le programme de sciences qui vont pas
voir en première ou en fonction des
filières inciter à la protection et au
dépistage un message que l'association
tente de faire entendre aux jeunes pas
toujours bien informés sur le sida ça se
passe pas dans ma ville
pendant qu'on n'a pas dans mon
environnement mai
c'est
enfin je sais que je sais ce que ça fait
à débit les kilomètres ce que les dégâts
que ça peut faire je me sens
personnellement concerné mais je sais
que ça doit être une maladie qui peut
faire beaucoup de ravages franchement ça
me fait de la peine pour les personnes
qui l'ont en termes de contamination
chez les jeunes l'association hf
prévention parle de chiffres alarmants
l'a récemment on a eu une étude1 d'une
mutuelle étudiante qui annonçait que 30%
des jeunes ne met pas le préservatif
donc dans les universités nous on
constate que effectivement 30% ces
nationale en île de france par exemple
on aurait plutôt tendance à dire que
c'est plutôt 50 à 60% présent que lors
du forum santé à elancourt l'association
a informé les collégiens de la ville sur
le sujet et le message semble être bien
passé faut bien se protéger que faut
connaître la personne avec qui on va
avoir un rapport voix il ya des gens qui
sommes qu'ils sont inconscients de ce
que l'on peu de ce que disent qu'ils
risquent s'ils se protège pas et il y en
a qui trouvent que c'est leur evra pas
mais ça peut ça peut arriver à n'importe
qui donc faut que tout le monde soit
soit prudent
prudent il faut bien entendu le rester
malgré les progrès réalisés depuis les
vingt années d'existence du sidaction
aujourd'hui grâce aux trithérapies on ne
meurt plus du sida mais le combat est
loin d'être terminé il ya aussi beaucoup
d'effets indésirables donc quand on
prend donc ses médicaments faut pas
oublier que ce sont donc des bombes
chimiques qui font que le virus et
contrôlés mais mine de rien cette bombe
chimique fait que les gens peuvent vivre
beaucoup plus longtemps et on fait tout
pour qu'il soit dépistée tôt pour être
effectivement traitée tôt parce que plus
on traite aux essais les nouvelles
recommandations que l'on va traiter tôt
plus on va gagner en durabilité les
membres de l'association hf prévention
et leurs bénévoles ont récolté des dons
vous pouvez également appeler
gratuitement le 110e jusqu'au 15 avril
vous prenez
c'est la fin de ce nouveau numéro avant
de nous quitter jetant un coup d'oeil
sur les dates à retenir avec son action
rire pour guérir l'association rire 78
propose des manifestations dans les
hôpitaux du département le mardi 29
avril prochain christian gabriel viendra
donner un spectacle avec le singe sont
ventriloque ce sera dès 15 heures à
l'hôpital andré mignot du chesnay le 2
mai le véhicule de l'établissement
français du sang stationnera à montigny
le bretonneux rendez-vous de 13h30 à
18h30 le long du boulevard vauban si
vous voulez donner votre sang check up
c'est terminé merci de votre attention
je vous donne rendez-vous dans un mois
d'ici là portez vous bien